okay so it's time to look at some of the
critical squares where White King can go
so first one is King to g1 after came to
G where it's very obvious that black has
to play the move Queen to h4 and we are
creating a checkmate throttle f2 White
has tried few responses over here if
Queen goes to the e2 or the f3 then
night to d4 is a very strong move and
accordingly if the Queen goes to the f1
square then rook can go to the f2 effort
square so not only saving the rook but
it's also creating a nasty pain on that
file considering all this the best move
over here is to move g3 and it is very
obvious that whenever the g3 occurs in
this in this lines we are always going
to sacrifice our second piece with the
move Knight captures g3 there are two
black pieces are hanging and let's see
what will happen if Y take either of
them so the first more I want to
consider is H captures g3 after this
black queen will simply take this pawn
with a check here King goes to the f1
square and now comes a very strong move
that is rook to F it so not only saving
the rook but black is planning to play
the move d5 and then Bishop to h3 check
which can be turns out very very nasty
to give you an example
one of my opponent at this position
played the move d4 and I respond 8s
Brava plan the d5 so hitting the Bishop
White has no option to capture this and
now comes pressure 2x3 check now White
has to be very very careful over here
because if he can surely play the move
King to e2 then Bishop to g4 and white
queen is a goner so that's not possible
so that means white White has to accept
this exchange sacrifice
but after this King has the only good
square left and that is King to Jeevan
please note that if I play the move
Bishop to g2 then he will lose the piece
with a check so that is not possible so
that's why White has to play the move
King to g1 after this we are going to
play the another aggressive move and the
trademark move that is Knight to g4 it
is always fun to play as such agonistic
moves when specially White Queen side
hasn't developed which I have mentioned
earlier in this video here my opponent
was really confused and he played the
best move which is also suggested by
Fritz that is the move sui 3 but still
it doesn't solve the problem here I
responded with the move Queen to g3
check and after King to h1 i played the
super aggressive move that is rook to e8
what a move
if you check out this with your computer
you will find that fight cannot take
either of the rook or the night I was
pretty sure that at this point my
opponent was literally shivering because
the next move suggested that he
desperately wants to do some Queen trade
here I give this check he put the Queen
in between I give another check and once
again he tried to exchange the Queen
after some thinking I accept at this
point the Queen trade because I can
clearly see this that after few
exchanges I'll emerge with a winning
position so I have a two active rooks
and most important that my queen side
hasn't developed yet
finally my opponent made a move which
develop a queen side piece but to his
horror he find out that the end is very
near
I play the best move in the game that is
rook to d6 and now there is a checkmate
fits in there which I think he
completely missed in a hurry he tried to
develop his Queen side pieces and he
played the move Bishop to d2 but this is
a disaster zone
there's a force mating sequence and it
starts with the move rook to g6 and
after king to h1 i played the move rook
to a fire and although my opponent has
three pieces on the board he cannot save
the net so this sort of fun you can get
in the tracks long at this point I can
also capture the rook in the corner but
after this we are going to play the
trademark move that is Knight to d4 and
sacrificing more material whether you
believe it or not but the best move over
here is s captures g3 any Queen side
developing move will be leads to
disaster for white this is the beauty
above the tracks level okay let's see
what we should do after H captures g3
after earth capsules e3 will definitely
capture with the Queen and my best
suggestion over here is you rather
satisfy with the draw and this is
especially good if you playing against
higher rate rate clear because you are
forcing them to make a draw nevertheless
if you are not happy about this position
then you can find out the alternate
solution especially against low-rated
the drawing sequence start with the moon
King to have fun and now important
movies Queen to f4 check because we want
to maintain our queen in the dark square
and white moves also force-wide has to
accept this perpetual because if he's
try to become a smartass and play the
move King to h3 then this will keep a
clear edge to the black let's start with
the move defy check and after King to s2
will play Queen to f4 check and after
King to g2 we have the strongest move of
the game that is Bishop to g4 and there
are so many times over here
first off his threat is capturing the
Queen the second of this threat is
capturing the bishop the thought of your
threat is Bishop to f3 which in some
cases leads to the mid or capturing the
rook in the corner and the final and the
very important point is now black is all
set to castle on the Queen side which
also safe on the King so all in all this
is winning position for black
so that was about King 2g1 the second
critical move is King - III afterwards
more or less black has to play the move
Queen to h4 and once again our idea is
to play the move Queen to f4
so if white is foolish enough to capture
the rook in the corner then Queen to f4
leads to the checkmate
second move that is rook to a fun then
not only black and save the rook but our
familiar plant comes into the picture
that is defy and quit Bishop g4 so that
is not good either for the white the
best move over here is the move g3 but
after the move g3 it is very obvious
that whenever this move appear on the
board we are always going to sacrifice
of a second piece with the move Knight
captures g3 once again two of the black
pieces are hanging let's see the
consequences if I capture the rook in
the corner then that comes the mate in
two let's start with the move Queen to
a4 check and after came to d3 we have
Queen to d4 checkmate and interrupt this
if white captures the knight with
setting up a trap that if black
foolishly capture the g3 then Queen to
f3 and white is winning but we are not
going to fall for this instead of that
we are going to play the move Queen to
d4 check and white needs to be careful
if white foolishly play the MOOC into e2
then the familiar trick will happen that
is Queen captures Bishop with a check
normally we will pick up the night in
the next move but will emerge with a
winning position
so that's why King to f3 is forced and
now we are going to play our trademark
move that is the move defy so it creates
some nasty threats the most potent is
now we are threatening Bishop to g4 and
capturing the queen of the white so
white has the only good defense left
that is rook to h4 so hitting the Queen
now the less we continue with the e4
with a check and after King to g2 black
cannot immediately capture the night
because if black cap to the night then
Queen to h5 is a lethal for black so
it's not possible but instead of this we
have a very strong move and I give you
few minutes can you find this amazing
move
okay so I hope you find this mode that
is castle it's a very effective move
right now White's Bishop is hanging and
black has created pin on the f5 so that
night cannot move I reached this
position two times in my game and in the
first game
my opponent responded with the move
Bishop to b3 so we just save this Bishop
well here I capture the night and now
black has two pawns for a piece but look
at the pathetic development of the Queen
side on top of everything black is
chatting - checkmate white on the f2 so
I'd need to defend that threat
my opponent responded here with the move
Queen to e2 and I responded very very
energetically so before he down off his
queen side piece I continue with my
initiative and that start with the move
G Phi
my opponent responded with the move rook
to h5 and now I played a very sneaky
move that is king - watch it
now if white has captured this pawn that
is let's say rook captures G Phi then
following line is very very effective
black can continue with the move Queen
to f6 attacking the rook and after the
move d3 which is protecting that rook
white can unleash this night with the
move Knight to d4 and now simply that
Queen is overloaded piece it cannot
defend all these three squares and if
Queen - even then Knight to f3 is a very
strong move and if Queen goes to the e3
then there follows the meet but start
with the move Queen to F in check King
to edge to Queens to s attack King to g1
and now rook F in checkmate
that's why white needs to be very very
careful at this position in the game my
opponent responded with the move Knight
to c3
but this doesn't turn out good either
there's a wonderful deflecting move over
here which can finish white off can you
find it
yup it's bishop to achieve for winning
stamp the first reason is White Queen
cannot capture the bishop because that
will leads to the mate after Queen f2
and the best move over here is Queen to
e3 but after that the very simple is
Queen to f6 threatening this checkmate
sequence starting with the move Queen to
have fun and not to mention the rook is
also hanging over here
my opponent responded with the move rook
to h1 but after Bishop to f3 check King
to g1 and Bishop captures h1
unfortunately my opponent cannot
recapture that bishop because Queen f1
is coming into the picture the last move
played was Queen to e2 afterwards the
final blow happens with the move Knight
to d4 it's funny enough that this Knight
is attacking the Queen
although Queen has the many squares to
go Queen cannot move my opponent
resigned over here
so that was about Bishop to b3 if you
open it is very aggressive by Nature he
might try this move that is Queen to h5
this is a course again so very high
rated pear and here I simply snap of
this Knight
now here Bishop captures d5 doesn't make
any sense because black is already a
piece down and like it's quite happy to
take a draw after Queen to f2 so there's
a force repetition and see the
importance of that Bishop it's covering
that vital h3 square so that's why
Bishop captures V far is not possible so
only critical try is done by white is
Queen captures at 7 check but after this
blacking will start running away so here
I responded with the MU King to f8 and
after Queen to H a check I played one of
the most wonderful move in the game that
is king to e7 it creates so many threats
I can't remember a single game where
black play the MU King to e7 and
creating this many threats let me
highlight them first of all there is a
queen check happening at the f2 square
this leads to the checkmate the second
is this Bishop is hanging and thought
which is also very important that is
black is threatening to play Bishop to
h3 and navin the White Queen
why it has the force response left and
in fact the only reply that is rook to
f4 but after this we can simply capture
this Brook and after white recapture we
can simply capture this piece and
although black is only pawn up in this
situation look at the pathetic Queen
side which hasn't developed yet and if
you check out with your computer this is
a winning position for black
so I hope with this analysis you can
feel now very confident after King
captures f2 and I hope to see your game
with quick check meeting the white king
it's time to move on to look at what
will happen if white plays other moves